[music]
Is that my buddy pharmacist Ben?
>> That's me. What's going on?
>> Oh man, pharmacist Ben. It has just been
a whirlwind of a day.
>> Yeah. In a good way. In a good way.
Right.
>> It's always It's always good
progress. Making progress.
>> Moving one foot. I used your line today,
by the way.
>> Which one?
>> Some I know, right? Somebody asked me uh
it was something that was difficult for
them. they what they felt was difficult
for them to do. And I said, "Have you
ever eaten an elephant?" And they said,
[laughter]
"That's not my line. I My fork."
>> I led into it, though. I led into it.
>> My line's fork by fork.
>> Well, bite by bite. I said, you know,
but yes, I I I led into that sentiment
anyway.
And they were they they laughed and were
appreciative and Yeah.
It was good. So, uh,
>> yes.
>> How are you?
>> I'm good, thank you. Haven't seen you
for a while.
>> Yeah, it's been been a couple days here
at least.
>> Yeah.
>> Three or four days.
So, uh, Pharmacist Ben, do you know what
our topic is tonight?
>> Nope. No idea.
>> No idea.
>> Not Not a clue. You didn't get my email.
Fantastic. Uh Andy, good to see you.
Bruce, thanks for being here. I don't
know who's on Rumble yet, but Rumble, I
got a couple uh phone calls in. So, some
people did get the email. Fantastic.
Uh today's uh title of the show is
>> Yes.
>> Why doctors are finally prescribing
fasting and yoga.
>> Oh, wait a minute. Wait a minute.
doctors prescribing fasting.
>> You don't prescribe fasting. You just
fast.
>> There's a quote.
>> Oh, you they're suggesting they're
recommending fasting.
>> Recommending fasting and yoga because
you sent me two articles.
>> Yeah. About fasting, about you. You
know, I've been talking about fasting
for years. I'm not fasting is is is has
been referred to as the perfect medicine
for years. Why? What happens when you
fast? First of all, you're not putting
stuff in, right? So, when you don't put
stuff into the body, your body sort of
functions like a self-cleaning
dishwasher. It runs when your dishwasher
runs without dishes in it, what happens?
It cleans itself out. The dishwasher
itself will get cleaned. When there's
when you run your dishwasher with no
dishes in it, right?
>> Does that make sense?
>> Mhm.
>> Is that is that yes or no? I want this
to make sense. So when you run your body
with no food in it, it cleans itself
out. That's called autophagy.
And what ends up happening is your body
actually will clean itself out. Not only
that, but you're not putting toxins in
the body either. So now your body
doesn't have to deal with toxins. Not
only that, but when you put any food in
your body, that requires nutritional
resources to process the food. Now, it
should be a wash because there should be
nutritional resources in the food. But
that doesn't always happen. In fact,
most of the time it doesn't happen. So
most food costs us nutrition.
So between the burden, the nutritional
burden on our bodies from food, between
detoxification, not putting toxins in,
and between the body cleaning itself
out, fasting is the perfect medicine,
not only for cancer, but for longevity.
We know that the less calories you eat,
the longer you live. That's been the
only proven way replicated replicated
replic replicated provable way to
increase longevity is fasting. So, I've
been talking about fasting for years,
including for cancer. However, the
medical professionals, and this is no
knock on doctors, I I have to always
preface what I say by saying I have a
lot of friends who are physicians. They
mean well. They're good people. They're
not they're not individually bad,
malicious, malignant, you know, human
beings who are trying to wreak havoc on
people's health. They're just going by
what they were taught. And they think
that if you don't eat, you're going to
lose, you're going to lose weight. And
because weight loss is something that
happens when people have cancer, they're
afraid to have people fast. What they
don't realize is it's not weight that
you need, it's muscle that you need. You
don't need fat, you need muscle. So
fasting, fasting is, in fact, fasting,
if you do it right, may help you build
muscle. And bodybuilders will fast like
the day before they do a contest to cut
up a little bit. So fasting is a very
very very important powerful cheap
inexpensive lifestyle protocol that you
can incorporate for yourself on your
own. And yoga is the same thing. You
know yoga yoga comes from the Sanskrit
word yoke which means to connect
>> to yoke right. So
yoga is really historically it was a way
to connect to God. It was a religion. It
was part of religion. And when we think
of yoga in the west here in this country
and in
>> exercise
>> yeah we think of it as moving your body
but there's really a lot of yogas
there's yoga of the mind they call that
raja yoga that means connecting to god
through your mind through mind power
there's bakti yoga that's connecting to
god through devotion there's uh karma
yoga that's connecting to god through
work there's dharma yoga that's the
connecting to god through your through
your your your mission your purpose in
life um there's probably there's agny
yoga which is another kind of yoga. I
don't remember what kind of yoga that
is.
>> There's also
yoga and aanga yoga. Those are body
yoga. I'm sorry.
>> There's also one yoga called hot yoga
where you connect to God.
>> Hot yoga.
>> Hot.
>> You call it vikram yoga. I call it hot
vikram yoga. I call it hot yoga because
you connect to God because you almost
die in that sauna like environment like
>> could be you got TO SAY OH GOD HELP ME
>> could be could be you know you ever hear
sweat lodges
>> sweat lodges
>> sweat lodges yeah Native Americans
connect to God in sweat lodges so yeah
heat is one way to do it
>> so yeah that is that's they're all ways
to connect to God that's initial
originally what they were for however by
holding your body in certain positions
you can improve um flexibility and
improve blood flow and improve the
movement and the movement electrical
energy, you know, without even getting
into chakras. I'm sure that has that
plays a role too, but you know, if you
don't even want to go into that because
that sounds a little bit woowoo. Not
that I don't believe in it because I do,
but you know, you don't have to go
there. You just talk about electrical
energy. So, you're facilitating the
movement of things when you do yoga. And
that is definitely helpful. I don't Was
that yoga and cancer? Did I send you an
article on yoga and cancer? Yes. Yes.
Yeah. Yeah. The body, you know, the body
is woefully underappreciated by most of
us. And when you do yoga or when you do
any kind of physical exercise, you're
reminded you have a body. You're
focusing on your body. And of course, if
you're sick, you want to focus on your
body. Your body needs some love.
Basically, in a way, you know, I don't
know if I ever told you a story. I broke
I had a really severe leg accident um a
few uh 30 years ago playing baseball.
Did I ever tell you that story? I had
this it was a
>> you were rounding second.
>> Yeah, I did. I told you the story. My
whole I was I was messed up, right? And
I remember uh after they, you know, they
did the surgery and I was, you know, I
was I was uh I couldn't walk for like
two months and I was just laying there
with my foot up, my leg up and uh I
remember feeling how sad my leg was.
>> My I could just feel the sadness coming
off of my leg. And I tried to send my
leg love and compassion and healing
energy just mentally, but I remember
just feeling the sadness coming off my
leg. When we're sick, our bodies are
sad. There's a real sadness. You want to
think of your body as needing some care
and love and attention. Most of the
time, we don't give our body any care
and love.
>> Yeah, that was very touching by the way.
>> What's that?
>> That you felt that your leg
>> I could really feel how sad I felt how
sad my leg was. I really did. And I have
God, praise God, I haven't really been
sick. So, but I imagine if I was sick,
the same thing would happen. You know,
our bodies need love and they need care.
And things like yoga as well as massage
or, you know, therapeutic touch or Reiki
or acupuncture, you know, these
alternative therapies, they're ways of
giving our body attention.
G giving a body attention that hasn't
had attention possibly for a lifetime.
For many of us, you know, we don't think
of our bodies unless we're sick. Have
you thought about your intestine today?
>> Probably not.
>> Yes, I did. Okay. Well, you then you got
a problem, but you wanted to follow.
>> I was thinking about my intestine as I
was peeling off nine I26s today.
>> Okay. Fair enough. Fair enough. So, so
that's one of the things we in longevity
do is we pay attention to the body. But
most people don't, you know, they don't
pay attention. I'm in the skin business
and people never pay attention to their
skin until something shows up on it,
>> right?
>> Or your or your heart, you know? Think
of what your heart's doing. Pumping a
billion times in a lifetime. a billion
boom boom boom boom boom boom for the
most part perfect. And so what yoga does
is it gives your body some love. It
gives your body some attention.
And that's to me that's that is if not
its most important certainly one of the
most important benefits of doing yoga
doing any kind of physical activity uh
if you're mindful about it.
you know uh pharmacist Ben what I found
um uh very intriguing and um what I say
hopeo hopebringing or what's the word
for you know hope inspiring or finding a
glimmer of hope in uh just was the fact
that you know just so many medical
standard medical professionals
who are making a living now by promoting
holistic sort of modalities and and it's
just
>> yeah regular doctors you mean like
regular medical professors
>> regular MDs
>> good good for them man
>> who are but but it seems that they're
they're they're doing it to put their um
to put their footprint into a space
>> they're they're coming into a space with
certain um cache that someone who
>> they may not believe in it. They may not
totally believe it is what you're
thinking.
I know they don't totally believe I mean
they totally they I know that they don't
totally
you know
um
no they don't totally believe in
nutrition number one for sure and um
they still will prescribe uh medications
for chronic diseases and they still will
look for certain things being a root
cause that are a symptom.
And um
but I am hopeful. I'm still hopeful.
>> I think I think it's heading in a good
direction. I think people like me and
you and Dr. Wallik and all the folks at
Youngevity in 30, 40, 50 years, we're
going to be considered like the
pioneers,
the way showers, the path clearers,
you know, the akin to like the pioneers
who uh who just who built America.
>> So I could be like the Davy Crockett of
nutrition.
>> Exactly. Daniel.
>> Oh man, I'm the Davy Crockett of
nutrition.
>> Cloth of nutrition.
>> That's That's you. Yes. That's you and
Doc Wallik. You and Doc are the Louiswis
and Clark.
>> We're the Louiswis and Clark of
nutrition. Yes. Exactly.
>> We're on the forefront. Doc was ahead of
me. You know, Doc was he was like alone
basically. There were a few other
people, but but you know, he was there
weren't a lot. I I was st I stood on his
shoulders. He was he was a good 10 years
before me, but I smelt a rat in pharmacy
school, you know, and and part of it is
somebody asked me how I got into this.
Part of it is, and you you're a little
younger than me, so you might not
remember this, but part of it was in the
1970s, something very interesting
happened. Early 1970s, it was called
Watergate.
>> Do you know what I'm talking about?
>> Oh, yeah.
>> Yeah. Yeah. But you're you you probably
know from a historical standpoint, but I
I was living
>> because I read all the president's men.
>> Okay. You read all the president's
events. So, what year were you born?
>> 72.
>> You were born 72. Okay. So, this all
happened in 72. So you were just kind
of, you know, you were a newborn, but I
was 12 or 13. And I remember thinking,
they're all liars. You know, I was only
12 and 13. And I said, they don't lie.
You can't believe anything anybody says.
You can't believe anything. You know,
people who you trust. And back then, you
know, the government, America, United
States of America, they wouldn't lie.
It's greatest country in the world and
this and that and the other. And, you
know, they were not going to lie to us.
And when I dawned on me that they were
all liars, I became very suspicious of
power and authority. And back then there
was all they would say things like don't
trust authority. And then when I
graduated pharmacy, when I went to
pharmacy school, not graduated, but went
to pharmacy school, I was like, what the
heck is going on here? We're studying
all these toxins and poisons and and
we're trying to mitigate poison and
we're trying to help people get healthy
by giving them poison. It just never
made sense to me. And so I got on the
nutrition bandwagon very very early uh
in my pharmacy career, but I was still I
still post-dated Doc by a good 10, 15,
20 years. Probably
Doc was doing it in the 60s, 60s and
70s.
>> I didn't get going till the 80s.
>> Ben, well, you're still a pioneer, man.
So, uh, and you, um, and you have a lot
you a lot more work to do. Um,
>> yes. A woman called in a few minutes ago
and I think she's watching on YouTube
now and she had said, you know, I've
been taking the products and I'm getting
them on Amazon, which I told her, take
this hand and turn it up this way and
take this hand and hold it like this and
then go like this for buying it from
Amazon [laughter] because,
you know, who does that doesn't help us,
>> you know? But she gets it fast, right?
And I'm like, "Yes, but you don't know
how fresh it is, right? How long has it
been sitting in Amazon's warehouse
>> and it's not helping the person who's
>> spending their time not charging you for
their time? Uh, and you know, so there's
an exchange there. But at any rate, she
said she's been taking the products."
And when I asked her, and yes, I'm
putting you on blast. I asked her, I
said, "So,
have you have you given up all the bad
foods?" You know cuz doc the primary
thing is he starts with foods that are
universally kind of thought not to be
good for us like fried foods. Have you
given up fried foods? Well, you mean
alltogether or can I just a week?
>> Zero. You don't have to have zero
tolerance for any of this stuff. But to
the degree that you do, the degree
you'll feel better and get healthier.
Yeah. Fried foods are a disaster for
health. I I got a call. I got a question
from, you know, I do a call before this
and I got a question I thought it was
really interesting about the ultimate
EFAs. You look at the ingredients in the
ultimate EFAs, you see flax seed oil and
tuna oil and fish oil and this oil and
that oil. And so the question is is I
thought oils were a problem, right? How
come they're in the ultimate EFAs?
What's the answer to that?
Well, number one, uh how we process
um uh you know, we
>> they're not heated. They're not heated
and they're protected they're protected
in a gel cap.
>> Protected in a gel cap, not heated, but
never touch oxygen because they're
processed in a nitrogen-rich room
if if you didn't know.
>> That's true. And they're they're not a
food oil. You're not eating them like
food.
>> It's not a food oil. you're not going to
sprinkle them on something, but you
know, if we're using uh a derivative of
sunflower oil or we're we're taking the
vitamin from that, we're not um you
know, we're we're taking the beneficial
piece of the sunflower seed to give you
nutrition. We're not um
>> right, you're getting a concentrated
nutrient, an essential fatty acid, which
is a concentrated nutrient. It's not a
food. You're not you're not you're not
eating t ingesting tablespoons or
teaspoons of it. You're ingesting a
couple of drops basically. And it's a
concentrated essential fatty acid
liquid.
>> And essential fatty acids are arguably
I don't want to say that they're the
most important, but they're among the
most important of all the nutrients.
They're part of the mighty 90 essential
nutrients. And they play a dramatic
dramatic role in multiple health systems
in the body including the hormone
system, the steroid hormone system, the
skin, uh the brain, the blood, the
heart, the liver, and the uh intestine.
And so it's crazy to deprive yourself of
these things, the ultimate EFAs. I think
they're the most important of all.
They're arguably the most important of
all of the nutrients. Let me take that
back. I don't like to say that, but
they're extremely important and they're
hard to get from food because we cook.
>> That's fantastic because you have so
many uh different nutrients that are
arguably the most important.
>> I know. I know. I know.
>> Well, what
>> I can name five that you love.
>> What's again?
>> I can name five nutrients in particular
that you absolutely love.
>> I know I'm sure you can because I always
say that. But here here's the thing. If
you have a baseball team, 1927 Yankees
or the 1976 Reds or I don't know who was
best who was considered the best
baseball teams ever, you know,
>> I like the 96 Yankees or
>> 96 Yankees. Okay, fine. So, I bet you
don't remember all the players on the 96
Yankees.
>> Of course I do.
>> No, you don't. Who's the catcher? Who's
the catcher?
>> Who's the catcher?
>> Who? Yeah, you heard me. I didn't
stutter. Who's the catcher?
>> Not Pada. Nope. That was 96, man. That
was way back. You don't know.
>> Jorge Patada.
>> Not 96.
>> Um,
okay.
>> Who was the right fielder?
>> Right fielder.
>> Yes.
>> Righter.
>> You don't know.
>> Center was Bernie. Um,
>> you don't know. When I tell you the
catcher, you're gonna laugh because you
never even thought of him as a catcher.
Probably.
>> Who? Tino. Who? Who is Tino's first
base?
>> No. When I tell you, you're going to be
like, he was the Yankee. He was a
catcher in the Yankees.
>> Who? Who's the catcher?
>> Joe Gerardi.
>> Gerardi. That's right. Gerardi.
>> People don't even know.
>> I forgot about Gerard. I forgot. Sorry,
Drew. Sorry, Gerardi. Um but what do you
call
>> but my point is my point is you know who
what's the most important position
>> right
>> all of them of course
>> exactly winning right it's a team and
that's why you know they're all
important all the nutrients are
important the mighty 90 essential
nutrients are all important but um I
have personal favorites put it that way
[clears throat]
>> you know and you're right thamin and
vitamin C probably who played right
field.
>> Didn't I just say Wait, wait. It was uh
>> You don't know. You don't know.
>> I do know. It was old school. He was
Winfield.
>> He was old.
>> Oh, no. It was uh
>> what's his name? Terrible. Don't tell me
it wasn't
>> Winfield.
>> And you called yourself a fan. And you
called yourself a fan.
>> Tall guy. What's his name?
>> Tall guy.
>> He was tall. He was mad tall is his
name. Paul O'Neal.
>> Paul O'Neal.
>> He was not tall.
>> Yes, he was.
>> Who is the third baseman?
>> Third basement.
>> You don't know anything. You go back to
school. [laughter]
>> Third basement was that guy.
>> That guy. But who was the second
basement?
>> Second basement?
>> Ah, you don't know nothing. You don't
know nothing about
>> Second was Nlock.
>> No.
Mariano Duncan. Mariano Duncan.
>> You don't know nothing. What was
>> Wade Bogs?
>> No. 96.
>> Yes.
You go back. You got to go back to
school. You don't know nothing.
>> All right. It's been a long time, man.
It's How many years is that since then?
>> 30 years.
30 years.
>> That's a long time.
>> I need I need more EFAs. All right.
>> Maybe. So, all right. far has been um as
much as I you know because because I do
enjoy your company and I can chat with
you about anything you know um one of
the uh another question I had for you uh
serious question was I had a woman
mentioned to me that her um oxygen
levels are are low
and you know she's been dealing with
some real issues and she spoke to Dr.
Randy even and um Dr. Ry's got her on uh
some repairerative and a lot of a lot of
detoxing.
>> Where are her symptoms? That's the root.
That's the fruit. That's the fruit is is
the option. What's going on? Yeah.
>> Her symptoms is she's had a lot of
edema.
>> Okay.
>> Uh she's had a lot of she's got some
congestive heart failure type of
>> stuff.
How old is she? How old is you? Say no
more. How old is she?
>> 60s, 50s, 60s, 70s,
>> 62, 65.
>> She's very young.
>> Mhm.
>> When you're that young and you're
dealing with congestive heart failure to
the point where you have edema and
hypoxia, that low oxygen, um, that means
something's been going on for a long
time.
>> So, that's good and that's bad. It's bad
because it's been going a long time and
you're in bad shape for 62. It's good
because when something has been really
dramatic, when when a biochemical
breakdown is dramatic, you can end it
dramatically, too. So, she can make
corrections and she can she can be a new
woman in a short period of time. She can
begin to make corre corrections right
away. So, first of all, the the low
oxygen and the um congestive heart
failure and the edema are all connected.
Her blood's not moving. All disease is
cell disease, but all cell disease is
what?
>> Preceded by
>> dirty blood.
>> Dirty blood. This is a blood issue. This
is a vascular issue. Now, congestive
heart failure is when the vasc when
she's not getting oxygen to the heart.
So, the heart doesn't work as well.
Heart doesn't work as well. The blood
doesn't circulate. The blood doesn't
circulate. the fluids leak out. That's
edema. When the blood doesn't circulate,
um
issues
secondary to dirty blood. So, what I
would be doing is asking this lady her
history about food, mostly starting
around food, but there's probably blood
sugar issues at this point. Also, the
good news, the bad news is there's a ton
of things that you there's that gone
wrong that have to go wrong in the body
for this to occur. The good news is
that's a lot of places for her to work.
I26, food diary, fasting, calorie
restriction, um, all the all the
nutrients. And by the way, and this is I
have to say this because this is really
really important and we don't emphasize
it enough. We always we talk about the
intestine, right? We talk about leaky
gut every every pretty much every call,
certainly every time I'm on we talk
about leaky gut, right?
>> Right. We talk about disbiosis, messed
up gut bacteria. We talk about mass
cells and histamine and and uh food
allergies and food intolerances etc.
>> But what was not recognized is when you
have an inflammatory condition in the
gut in the intestine.
Not only do you now have to deal with
toxicity, but you're also going to be
dealing with malnourishment
because nutrients are absorbed through
the intestine. Once the intestine is
inflamed, you're not going to absorb
your B's, your electrolytes, your
vitamin C, probably your fats and your
fatty vitamins, your aminos. You're
going to be functionally starving. So,
in addition to targeting
the gut for this woman, which you should
be, food diary, eliminating problem
foods, daily digest, all that, get on a
liquid nutritional supplement program to
get some nutrients into your blood so
you're not starving.
BTT.
Get on the BTT and get on it quickly and
do small doses. If this woman is
serious, is she Do you know Do Who is
she exactly? Do you know her?
>> This is a woman who's been using
Youngevity well before I met her.
>> Well, she's not doing it right. Have her
come on the call on Friday.
>> I think I think I think Dr. Randy
identified she's dealing with some
toxicity.
Have her come on the call on Friday.
>> Okay.
>> Have her come on call on Friday.
Everybody's dealing with toxicity.
That's that goes without saying
everybody's t we can't be alive if
you're drinking the water and eating the
fish and the ice cream and the milk and
the meat. How can you How are you not
going to have toxicity? The vegetables,
the glyphosate. Of course you're going
to Everybody's toxic. That's
>> jabs.
>> What's that?
>> Jabs.
>> The jabs. All that. Abs. Oh, did she
have the jab, too? Well, she's she's
she's she had some dental work done and
she just
>> all that all that. But you locus of
control, remember locus of control, the
jab, the dental work, you can't control
that. She already had the dental work.
Okay? So, you know, you can be bummed
about it, but you can't really do
anything about it now or the jab. But
what you can do is you can stop the
stream
the the stream of toxicity that's
entering into the bloodstream every day,
multiple times a day. You with me?
That's where you have control. That's
the place. Is this the woman who talked
about fried foods?
>> No.
>> Okay. All right. So, so right from the
get-go, you have a powerful place where
you can work. And again, I'm not Mr.
Food guy, even though we we I talk about
the digestive system and the gut all the
time, right? It's not because I'm Mr.
Food Guy. It's because that is the
source of the dirty blood. Unless you're
unless you're injecting and it's where
we have control. We have control over
that. You don't have control over your
dental work. That's done. You don't have
any control over the jab if you got it.
That's done. But you have control over
every single day what's getting into the
bloodstream through the intestine. Go
ahead. I'm sorry.
>> She uh So, she said when I spoke to you
earlier, I was doing okay. And then
later on the day, I didn't feel so good.
I said, "What did you eat?" She said, "I
had a steak."
You know, when I was on the subway and
I'm just like, well, clearly you're not
digesting very well because you know
that something happened there. I mean,
>> exactly.
>> Maybe you don't want to have steak
tomorrow.
>> Yeah. Steak is not a, you know, it could
be a quality food theoretically,
but not the way we eat steak.
>> So, we should just be eating it raw with
the blood leaking. But you know I mean
ideally I suppose if you have I don't
think humans have the enzymes in order
to process them. Most of us are don't
have enough enzymes but a wild animal
would and actually you know now I think
about it there's enzymes in the raw
meat.
>> Did you know that when you eat raw meat
when an animal eats raw meat like kills
the kills the uh analopee like right
there's lots of enzymes in the meat the
meat digests itself. That's one of the
ways that wild animals can eat um
they can digest and process formerly
alive meat because when it's fresh it's
got lots of enzyatic activity
[snorts]
[gasps]
alterant as usual question
um can you please ask Ben what I can
take when I have been eating raw whole
vegetables and one fruit a day but my
stomach has severe here. Painful gas
since last night. Stomach, chest pain,
nausea, feeling. What can I take?
>> Get some cellulace.
Is there cellulace in our Ultimate
Enzymes?
>> I think there is.
>> Good googly moogly.
>> And start using probiotics, too. That
might help.
>> Cellulace is an enzyme that breaks up
cellulose. And cellulose is a fiber that
a lot of people have problems with.
Cellulose will feed bacteria if you have
a SIBO. So cellulace is an enzyme that
breaks up cellulose. And I'm not sure if
it's in the Ultimate Enzymes, but a lot
most digestive enzyme supplements will
have cellulace in it.
It's interesting though, we had this
idea that veget was I talking about did
you and I talk about this on our list?
Well, I'm familiar with here and I don't
see cellulace. I see uh uh protease,
amaase, lipase, pepign, pepsin,
bromelene, oxile, bet, betane,
hydrochloride,
and pancreatin.
>> You'd have to get extra cellulace.
I'd like to know what they ate and I'd
like to know how often this happens.
They said LA it happened last night, but
it hasn't happened before.
The true enzyme I believe and the digest
FX have cellulace.
>> Yeah.
>> The true
uh chron magnesium
catalase
pectin amalayase cellulace.
>> Yeah. Cellulase is the one you're
looking for.
>> True. The true enzyme. Of course, Dr.
Ariaza's got that covered.
>> Dr. Ariaza is the bomb.
>> Yeah. And then digest FX also
has
lactase cellulace gluccomalase.
>> Wow.
>> I never heard of gluccomalase. What is
it? Gluccomase.
>> Mhm.
>> I never heard that one.
>> Uh yeah, Digest FX. Now that I'm reading
it, I see why it's pretty dog on good.
It's got a proprietary fungal enzyme
blend. Uh but at any rate, um that's
that one. Yes. And we will
>> Let's get some calls here before we go.
I only got 20 more minutes.
>> Well, we got a couple we got a couple
calls. Yeah. I I saw Yes, Victor. I saw
your Yankees answers. He said Wade Bonds
had a key. Go ahead. But Wade Bogs was
our enemy for too long for me to call
him a Yankee.
>> Paul O'Neal was the right fielder.
>> Who was?
>> Wade Bogs was a was a
>> Who was the right fielder? Who' he say
was a right fielder though?
>> Paul O'Neal like you said.
>> Yeah, Paul O'Neal. Right.
>> Yeah, it was Paul O'Neal. Uh but um but
Bernie was a center and who was the left
fielder. It switched because Tim Reigns
was on one of those teams.
>> Tim Reigns. Tim Reigns. That's who it
was.
>> Um,
>> yeah.
>> Um, okay. So,
another question came in from Bruce. Let
me see if I could find it.
Uh,
what causes disease? Yeah, Bruce. Bruce
is
Oh, yeah. Bruce, I'm sorry. Let me get
this up for you. Ben, can you You can't
see the screen, can you, Ben?
>> Uh, yeah.
Yeah, I see it.
>> Okay, hang on a second.
Hang on a second.
>> Where are you? What's that sound?
>> Oh, you hear the ambulances going by and
fire trucks?
>> Ambulance?
>> I'm in this dog on
>> place called New York City.
>> I was there last week, man. Holy moly.
>> Yeah. Not your
>> That is That is not an easy place to be.
Not your cup of tea, huh?
>> No, sir.
>> Yeah. Well, welcome to the jungle. So,
so now
>> Yeah. Welcome to the jungle.
>> Let's see here. What do you think of
this pharmacist Ben?
>> Oh my gosh. That person has got to be
very old and very sick. Make it bigger.
>> Huh?
>> What What makes you say very sick.
>> Put Put it on. I'll tell you why. Make
it bigger.
>> Okay. I I can't make it bigger in this
format, but I can I can do it elsewhere.
Hang on.
What makes you say that?
>> Uh because the skin is the canary in the
coal mine. And for to have that kind of
dramatic uh it's not even the skin,
that's more like the it's the skin
technically. It's the part underneath
the skin where the blood is the dermis.
And for that to be that wounded and that
traumatized means there's some serious
metabolic issues. Well, I'd like to see
it a little closer.
Is a person very old?
>> Uh, yeah. I do believe
>> 80s or 90s. 80s or 90s.
>> You know what, Bruce would have to
Bruce, how old is the person in the
picture? Um, I would have to I would
have to say likely 80s or 90s because
That's a very that that doesn't happen
unless there's been a lot of breakdown.
>> I think Bruce mentioned that he lives in
a retirement community.
>> That's what it looks like. People in
retirement communities typically don't
get the right kind of food
and they're breaking down. Yeah, that's
that's very significant.
That's a very significant issue. So,
look, in a perfect world, that's very
treatable. But by the time the body gets
to that point, that means it's been
breaking down for so long, it it's been
suffering from lack of care for decades.
So most of the time, you're not going to
like put the brakes on it and then
change your entire life, right? But
theoretically, there's tons you could do
with that. I would be pounding the BTT,
first of all, lots of vitamin C.
I'd be correcting any digestive or
metabolic issues. That goes without
saying. And um protein, amino acids and
peptides and protein, whey protein, TMR
shake would stay away from anything um
that's processed, that's highly cooked,
that's extruded or like cereal grains or
cereals I should say. Um and anything
like sweets, that kind of stuff.
>> Is there any way to get protein in a
pill form?
>> Yeah, you protein pill form. can't get a
lot of it though. But they make protein
protein tablets I'm sure.
>> But what about young Japanese stuff?
>> The best we can do is
>> Yeah, I don't I I you know, that's a
good question. I don't think I've ever
really seen protein tablets, but there's
no reason not to. They they couldn't
come in tablets. You just compress the
protein.
>> And then would am would uh uh aminos
like the HGH aminos would that help?
>> Amos would help them and protein would
definitely help them. Um, connective
tissue protein. That's what I would be
doing. Glycine.
Um,
uh, collagen, collagen peptides,
um, gelatin.
>> My dad's legs look like this, too. Now,
>> how old is he?
>> Not that old.
>> Well,
>> old am I? He's I'm I'm So, he's got to
be like 74.
>> That's a major That's major breakdown.
That's MBFA. That's a That's a serious
case of MBFA.
>> He He committed to taking He won't do
any of my drinks,
>> but he he But he'll but he now says
he'll take the pill forms or whatever I
got. So
>> why would people be resistant?
>> Because he wants to drink diet soda.
>> He doesn't want to quit diet soda.
>> And and my and my tangy tangerine will
interfere with his diet soda.
>> I don't know.
I can't explain it.
>> I'm putting you on blast. Everybody gets
to do what they want to do.
>> Mary Mack is saying, "High aminos." What
do you think about that comment that
Mary Mack made?
>> High aminos.
>> HGH aminos. I'm sorry.
>> Oh, HGH am. I don't know what's what
what they are. I'd have to see them. I
can't speak.
>> I'll tell you what's in there. Um,
there's a question here.
Uh, a couple of questions here. Uh, I'll
start with um our buddy uh Andy's
question because he was on one of the
first people on and Wyoming Annie is on.
She says our favorite late night duo
um
uh a Monday night duo. Thank you Wyoming
Annie as usual for being on with us and
Bruce
and Andy. But Andy's question is,
"What's Ben's take on neuro theapy
with a celiac ganglion?
My doctor injected propane with DMS.
DSMO."
I think that's DMSO. Oh,
>> is that D? and put neural drops on the
skin with analog PEMF.
Lifechanging results.
Yeah. Well, they basically numbed the uh
the the the celiac ganglia are it's like
a a complex of nerves that are in the
upper abdomen,
>> upper part, like right up up here. and
they regulate um digestive functions
>> and they're associated with pain
>> so if you have celiac because you're
eating the wrong foods you're going to
end up with some kind of nerve problem
and pain. So what they're doing is
they're reducing the inflammation in the
nerves and they're giving them an
anesthetic. Procine is an anesthetic, a
number, but why don't you just stop
eating the freaking triggering foods
instead of having medical intervention?
Yeah, I'm sure it is relief, you know,
because now you've anesthetized the
nerves,
but that's not going to that's not good
for you in the long run to anesthetize
the nerves. Yeah, it's going to take get
rid of the pain. And the DMSO probably
is an anti-inflammatory.
So, they're reducing the inflammation,
but why don't we just stop eating the
food that's causing the inflammation?
Celiac is a gluten disease,
right? Are you there?
>> Yes, it is 100%. Why don't we stop
eating the the triggering foods? That
that to me that makes much more sense.
Although I can imagine this, you know,
this guy's gotten some relief. They
numbed his they numbed the nerves that
associated with the pain. So, yeah, I
could see that. He's probably He's
probably thrilled.
>> People don't want to give up pizza. Uh
uh Johnny J on Rumble says, "I seem to
be GI sensitive when t with taking BTT.
Any suggestion on how much I should put
in a 16.9 ounce bottle?
>> Yes, you go to taste where you like the
taste and you do it with food and it's
much better to do divided doses than to
try to do it all at once.
It's not a GI problem, it's a BTT
problem. The BTT absorbs water. You can
tell it absorbs water because what
happens when you put it in water? It
dissolves. So, as your BTT is passing
through your digestive tract, it's going
to pull water with it. It's a water
magnet.
>> It make sense?
>> Mhm.
>> So, as it's going through, it's pulling
water with it. It can cause bloating in
the intestine. The large intestine, the
large intestine is where water is
absorbed, is is sucked out. It's how
your stool doesn't have water. It's like
a solid. One of the jobs of the large
intestine is to suck water out of that
mass of food that drops in from the
small intestine. If you take BTT, that's
going to put a flood of water. If you
take enough of it and you're not
absorbing it, it'll take a flood of
water and it'll go into your large
intestine. It can cause all kinds of
havoc, bathroom havoc. So, you want to
do smaller doses, A. You want to do
divided doses throughout the day, B. and
you want to take it with food. See,
and BTT, BTT is a great beverage to take
with food, by the way. You know, if you
like to drink something with your meals,
BTT is perfect.
>> Absolutely. Love
>> you're going to get all those nutrients
and your digestive juices will be going.
So, you'll be able to absor you'll
maximize the absorption.
>> Uh Cindy Lou, is guar gum safe in
products?
You know, there's a lot of controversy
on guarant. I wouldn't do a lot of it
orally, but a small amount's not going
to hurt you.
>> Uh, Roger Clemens is still our enemy.
Um, okay. So, uh, uh, Andy's mentioning
they were addressing the sympathetic
fight or flight, which wasn't allowing
me to produce stomach acid.
>> Is this the guy with the gang, Leon?
>> Yes,
>> that makes sense. So when when the
sympathetic nervous system is your
emergency nervous system, if you have
celiac and you are um not following the
protocol and you're doing things that
trigger your celiac, that will activate
the emergency nervous system and that
will definitely suppress stomach acid.
That is true. So the propane and the
DMSO are telling the nervous system to
stand down that you don't have an
emergency, but they're doing it by
poisoning it.
Procane poisons it. TMSO not quite the
same, but propane anesthetizes the
nerves. That in essence poisons the
nerves. So, yeah, I can see what they're
thinking, but it makes more sense to not
do the triggering foods, I would think,
than try to drug your drug yourself out,
drug yourself off the problem, away from
the problem.
>> Okay, for Mrs. Ben, uh, I'm going to try
and let you go early today. So, I want
to do a couple rapid fire questions for
you that I don't think that you saw my
email. So, I'm going to ask you
what you ask
>> these questions in rapid fire
succession.
>> Wait, wait a minute. What are you going
to try and is going to be gotcha, Ben?
You're going to gotcha me?
>> Yes. Anybody who's got a question that
can stump pharmacist Ben?
>> No, I don't know everything. will get a
free
>> No, I don't know.
>> EFA. Not a bottle of EFA. Get one EFA
for free.
>> I don't know.
I'm I'm not going to uh own that. I know
I know some stuff more than most people,
but that doesn't mean I know
>> you know you know a darn good bunch
amount of stuff. And and keep in mind,
pharmacist Ben, you have AI as your
assistant if you need. So, um, let's
see. Tonight's show, Pharmacist Ben, uh,
I'm going to ask you some questions
about, uh, certain pharmaceutical drugs,
>> okay?
>> And you're going to tell me
what we might, uh, do,
um,
to prevent needing to use them. But, but
first,
I want to address Ivon's question.
Uh, Ivonne says, "Can Ben decipher the
difference between proteins, amino
acids, and peptides?" Yeah,
>> we've done that before, but go right
ahead.
>> All right. A protein is a very complex
molecule
>> that's made up of lots of peptides.
>> Technically, they call them a
polyeptide.
So, protein is made up of a bunch of
peptides. They could be they could be um
wrapped around and very they're very
complicated. They be globular and like a
ball of yarn. Think of a think of a a a
pearl necklace.
A pearl necklace is made up of pearls,
right? The pearls are the amino acid.
The necklace is the peptide.
>> If you take the peptide and wrap it
around into a ball and turn it into like
a ball of yarn,
>> it becomes a protein. Now, some proteins
are long chains and other proteins are
globs.
They're fibrous proteins and there's
globular proteins. But either way,
they're made up of a bunch of pearl
necklaces which are in turn made up of a
bunch of pearls. So amino acids equal
pearls, necklaces equal peptides, and
proteins equal complex peptides.
Okay, either globular or fibrous.
>> That is very clear. Very clear. Um,
thank you Ivonne for asking the
question.
Um
um
>> so what are you gonna ask me? What's my
questions here?
>> Okay, before we get there, Key is
asking, "What about contraceptives
suppressing the body over time and
long-term effects and birth control
IUD?"
>> Okay, the IUD is not quite as you're
still interfering with hormones. The
steroid hormone system is not to be
messed around with. you you mess around
with your steroid hormones at your own
peril. Birth control pills, which are
steroid hormones in very very high
concentrations. Fake steroid hormones,
artificial, poisonous, synthetic steroid
hormones, are an absolute disaster. And
I, in my humble opinion, they're among
the worst drugs a human being could
take, the birth control pill. Obviously,
they're convenient, but other than that,
they're awful drugs and they wreak havoc
on the hormone system. And then the IUD
is not quite as bad, but it will still
mess up your hormones. So, you know,
contraception is contraception. And you
know,
>> what is the IUD? Is just a device?
>> Yeah, it's a device.
>> Okay.
>> Intrauterine device. IUD. Intrauterine.
>> How is How is that device problematic?
>> It it chang
>> Yeah. Well, you're putting something in
your body. It's going to change the
hormone system.
>> Is is it medicinal the device?
>> No, it's not necessarily medicinal. It's
mechanical, but the fact that you now
have a mechanical substance in your
uterus is going to affect how hormones
are secreted. You can't put something,
you can't put a solid object in your
uterus and not change the biochemistry.
>> You're changing the structure, which
means you're going to change
[clears throat] the function.
>> Okay. Well, Key, I guess he's answered
that. Your thoughts about the injections
for birth control?
>> They're awful. They're awful. The human
body is designed to give birth. That's
its main role in life is to give birth.
So, the only way to have to have like
cons to have like a a sperm meet an egg
or the potential for a sperm to meet an
egg to be sexually active and not have a
baby is to like completely overwhelm the
system because it's designed to make
babies. We're designed to make babies.
That's our role as biological entities.
So everything is set up to make babies.
So to, you know, if you're going to be
sexually active and expect to not make a
baby, you've got to go out of your way
either with a serious drug or a
mechanical device or, you know, a
prophylactic, a condom, but you have to
really go out of your way to not make
the baby because the body wants to make
babies. In fact, we have, I don't know,
you probably know this, we have a
fertility epidemic in this country.
around the world.
>> Around the world there's a fertility
epidemic which tells you we must have
really mucked up the system
>> because the body is designed to make
babies. So for us to have a fertility
epidemic means we must have really done
a number on our on our biochemistry and
on the environment which of course we
have.
>> Bruce is asking uh what are the chances
of coming back healthy after a
colonoscopy colostomy bag has been
>> sold. Lots lots you could do. You have
to change the way you eat. You have to
completely change your life. But yes,
there's lots you could do. Absolutely. I
don't know. I'd have to get some more
details.
>> Would a doctor remove the bag after 90
days? Is that possible?
>> Yeah, absolutely.
>> I told Bruce I told Bruce no that tell a
person don't get the bag because me
personally, I have two people in my
family. They told them, "Oh, get the
bag. We're going to fix you up." And
they were dead within a year.
Is that right? Well,
you know, if you need the bag, you need
the bag. There people live, you know,
there was a football player, Ralph
Bernerski. He He was a kicker for the
Pod for the Chargers. And
>> he didn't have the bag while he was
kicking, did he?
>> Yeah, he did.
>> No, he did not.
>> Yeah, he did. Yeah, he did. He played
football with it.
>> So, yeah, you could you can have a good
life with the bag.
>> You You hear what Victor's saying?
Vitamin E and salt help with fertility
in civilizations where women eat little
salt, they have fewer babies.
>> Vitamin E, the technical name for
vitamin E is tcopherol, which means to
bear children. Tocopherol means to bear
children. Vitamin E is the
quintessential fertility vitamin because
it protects the sperm and the egg.
Vitamin E is a really interesting
vitamin
and arguably it's the most important.
No, I'm just kidding. It's not.
[laughter]
I I just said that for your
>> I was I was sitting there.
>> I was kidding you. [laughter]
>> You got me.
>> I just wanted I figured you get a kick
out of that.
>> Okay.
>> All right. All right. We missed rapid
fire.
>> No. Wait. Okay. Well, okay. So,
everybody
to No,
Andy is
>> to bear children. Tocopherol means to
bear children. toot trienols are
different and that's goes that goes to
the whole that goes the whole
fascinating nature of vitamin E. Uh so
you have the vitamin E vitamins are uh a
family. There's no one vitamin E. It's a
family. There's no one vitamin A. It's a
family. There's no one vitamin K. It's a
family. Even vitamin D is a family,
although not quite as significant as the
other ones. So the the fat soluble
vitamins are families. Vitamin E is made
up of eight children. We the molecule
called vitamin A has eight versions
derivatives.
They're all considered vitamin E in the
sense that they're found together in
nature. You need to have them in the
diet. You can't make it. Uh but there's
eight versions of it or eight varieties.
We'll say you have four that are called
tcopherols
and you have four that are called
tootrienols.
Alpha uh beta, delta and gamma. I think
that's it. Alpha, beta, delta, and
gamma. Alpha, beta, delta, and gamma.
Okay. Yeah, somebody say that. Alpha,
beta, delta, and gamma. Right. And each
one of them has a little bit slightly
different effect in the body. The most
common one is alpha tcopherel. That's
the most common form of vitamin E. But
the tocotrienols have a little bit more
antioxidant oomph than the tocopherols.
But they're all important. The best
thing you could do if you really want to
go all out is get mixed tcopherols and
tootryenols. And those are all thrown
together or get it from food. But it's
hard to get it. It's hard to get vitamin
E from food.
>> Uh next time let's talk about vitamin E
on Friday. It's just a it's a really
very interesting vitamin.
>> Damn.
>> Here's a little tip for you. If you take
if you have a burn or some kind of
wound, uh if you're healing from a zit,
you ever you have pop a zit, a big old
zit, and you get this big yucky thing
left over. High doses of vitamin E taken
for a week or so, like 1,200 IU,
usually about 400 IU is a good dose, but
1,200 IU taken for four, five, six days,
that will you you'll be amazed at how
fast you heal with that. It's amazing
from healing.
Well, Andy, I you know, Andy, I hope
you're a health coach. If you're not a
health coach, you need to call
8559493377.
I'd like to have a conversation with
you. I'm sure I've said this to you
before, but we we need go give us a call
tomorrow, sign up uh and and become a
health coach. Somebody like you needs to
be helping more people. Same as a brain
waveforms.
Ivonne, you got me lost. And Ben, I
don't have time for my full rapid fire,
but I'm going to ask you about one.
>> Okay.
>> Katruda.
>> What are you asking?
>> Katruda is a monoconal antibbody used in
immun immuno
oncology to treat various cancers. Maybe
that's not a good one. Including lung
cancer, head and neck cancer. What do
you want to know?
>> Well, my my thought was what would be
the root not fruit version of
uh
>> well cancer is a cancer is a little
different but think about what Kruda is
doing. Kruda is shutting down the immune
system.
>> Okay, so um I'm sorry. Kuda is
preventing cancer cells from shutting
off the immune system. One of the things
cancer cells do is um they suppress
immunity so they can survive because the
im immune system will kill the kill the
cancer. So cancer cells have a mechanism
for um suppressing immunity.
>> You follow they have a way of hiding
themselves of of protecting themselves
from the immune system.
They can disguise themselves. They do
all kinds of they have all kinds of
tricks. Cancer is brilliant. Cancer
cells have a way of taking advantage of
mechanisms where the immune system is
suppressed for their own benefit. KUDA
prevents CA cancer cells from disguising
themselves. That's a good way to put it.
So that your tea cells can recognize
them and kill them.
>> Cancer cells are masters of disguise.
And now you know it's all it's this like
kind of like um um chem it's this uh you
know how like uh in in the in with a war
metaphor like one country will come up
with a weapon another country will come
up with a way to protect themselves from
that weapon and then the other country
will come up way of of taking care of
the the protective way protective device
that this other country came up with.
They'll go back and forth or in football
they'll have offenses and they'll come
up with fancy plays and the offenses
will be you know going crazy for a
couple years. then the defenses will
catch up and they'll come up with ways
of, you know, it goes back and forth
like that. Well, that's kind of what
happens with cancer cells. Cancer cells
have a way of disguising themselves and
hiding themselves and we uh scientists,
drug companies basically have ways of of
overriding those mechanisms.
I was just reading of a really cool one
where they're actually making receptors,
synthetic receptors that actually have
an antibbody that can target specific
cancer cells. There's there's all kinds
of stuff they're doing now with genetics
to produce
mis, for lack of a better term,
heat-seeking missiles for specific
cancer cells that just kill that cancer
cells. Those are called monoconal
antibodies, these drugs. And they're not
just used for cancer. They're used for
lots of things. And these monoconal
antibodies are number one extremely
expensive, thousands and thousands of
dollars a month. And number two, they're
heavily advertised. In fact, most drug
advertising, probably 80% of drug, at
least 80% of drug advertising is for
monoconal antibodies. That's the ones
you see advertised. There's a few other
ones they'll advertise, but the bulk of
ads are for these new drugs because the
profits are so huge and insurance
companies pay for them.
>> Pharmacist Ben, uh, take a stab at how
much, uh, annual sales last year was for
Kuda.
>> Billions.
>> Take a number. Pick a number.
>> Well, I'll put it this way. Probably
cost $10,000 a month at least for Kruda.
>> Okay. But
>> so you're talking about $120,000 a year
per patient for one person.
>> So I I'd say probably I don't know $50
billion.
>> 30 billion.
>> Yeah, I can see that.
>> 30 30 billion.
>> Yeah.
>> We're in the wrong business.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
>> But but uh yeah, pharmacist B. I let you
go there. Uh Ivonne wants to know what's
the best vitamin E?
>> The best vitamin E in terms of brand or
in terms of what do you mean by best?
I don't know what that means. The the
best brand.
>> No, I don't think she's talking about
brand.
>> Oh, alpha. Alpha tcopherol.
Uh, it's not. There's no theta. Ah,
she's saying brain waves. I see. No,
it's it's alpha, beta, delta, and gamma.
There's no theta tool.
>> It's alpha, beta, delta, and gamma. But
she's she's right. Brain there's alpha.
You know about brain waves?
>> Alpha there's alpha brain waves. beta,
theta, delta, gamma, and I was just
reading of another one. You know, they
keep finding new ones, but um activating
activating your alpha and theta brain
waves is a very important part of
health. We can talk about that next
time. [clears throat]
>> Do you ever hear the Silva method? Do
you ever hear Jose Silva, the Silva
method?
>> No.
>> Uh my histamine intolerance improved
quite a bit by cutting down on meat
consumption and replacing meat with whey
protein and eggs. Why is this? Uh, it
could have a lot of things. It could
have to do a lot of things. I'd have to
see what kind of meat you're eating,
first of all, and how you're cooking
your meat or what you're putting with
your meat when you're cooking. I don't
know what that means. Meat consumption.
It could be all kinds of stuff. Um, but
proteins are typically allergenic and I
don't while meat proteins usually don't
have a problem with, I'd have to see
what kind of meat they were eating. Whey
protein uh actually nourishes is very
nourishing for bacteria. So, that makes
sense. And uh I don't know. I'd have to
see what kind of meat you're eating.
>> Why are people injecting with peptides?
>> Peptides are uh
trigger healing. Many peptides trigger
healing, uh change biochemistry,
and have therapeutic benefits.
And they're easy. They're relatively
cheap. Relatively cheap. And they're not
drugs. They're not pharmarmacology. Your
body doesn't have to detoxify them like
they do drugs. And you can get some good
benefits with injecting.
>> You don't mind people injecting them.
>> It's not like a drug. It's certainly not
like a drug. You don't have to detoxify
them like a drug.
>> I drugs are poisons.
>> Peptides aren't poisons. But still, you
know, I I I don't I like to think of the
body as self-contained. Like you could
get everything you need from foods and
supplements and nutrients. Peptides are
not in that category, but there are some
pretty I've seen some pretty good
benefits with peptides.
>> Injectable peptides. Well,
>> pharmacist Ben, it's that time again. I
appreciate all
times
>> and
uh and and Keley and everybody else.
Friday, we have to figure out what we're
gonna talk about. I have to watch this
show again because you gave so many
unexpected great nuggets and we
appreciate you. And and last parting
words, do you want anybody to join the
team?
>> Yes. We want to train you to be like AJ
and me.
>> We're we will train you so that you will
know what we know and you'll be able to
help people like we're helping people.
Get out there, sign up uh under AJ or
under myself or whoever you're signing
up under. We will train you. We will
teach you. You'll learn the longevity
products. You'll learn how to help your
friends, your loved ones. You'll learn
to understand health so you're not a
victim when you go to the doctor and you
don't have to just do whatever uh
whatever the medical professional
happens to tell you what to do because
you'll be able to ask good questions and
you'll understand your body. We'll train
you in health from A to Z and you'll
make money bonus. You'll make a good
living. Some people make quite a
significant living.
>> Absolutely. Some people make a lot of
figures every month doing this.
>> A lot of figures doing this.
>> You're the man. Pharmacist Ben. We will
see you on Friday.
>> Yes. I'm looking forward to it.
>> Thank you, sir.
>> Bye.
[music]
>> [music]
>> Ooh.
Hey.
[music]
>> [music]